thanks for all your comments on YouTube
I read them all and I still insist that
Aquaman is the best superhero ever
nothing you say can dissuade me lately
there's been a groundswell of comments
demanding that I rant about bronies
grown men who loved my little pony's
Friendship is Magic cartoon even though
they're well outside of the target
demographic of prepubescent girls oh you
want me to ran about bronies well guess
what I refuse I've never seen the
cartoon myself but I just don't
understand this hatred and vitriol
that's heaped on bronies what you hate
them because they enjoy a kitty
franchise that's a transparent device
for sowing hasbro toys well if you feel
that way and you're also a fan of
transformers or Star Wars or Naruto then
guess what you are a hypocrite those are
absolutely Kitty franchises too and they
absolutely exist to sell you toys and
tie-in merchandise comic books come on
men and brightly-colored underoos
punching each other
kitty-kitty-kitty besides we are in a
new golden age of kid-friendly
entertainment any adult who can
acknowledge how clever and innovative
Toy Story movies and Mario games and
Harry Potter books are is just hurting
themselves also I hear this My Little
Pony show was created by Lauren Faust
who worked on Powerpuff Girls and
Foster's Home for Imaginary Friends both
witty gorgeously animated Kitty shows
that adults can also enjoy so let's hear
it for the bronies what am I are you
gonna watch this show oh god no I'm a
grown man why would I do that
where do you stand on bronies let me
know in the comments and subscribe to
the wired Channel